anybody's death is so unfortunate I
think what is you know even more so in
the situation of Heath Ledger's passing
is that he seemed to be a Hollywood good
guy you know rather than caught up get
caught up in Hollywood you know he moves
to Brooklyn when he was an up-and-coming
actor you know you know through his late
teens he would turn down roles that his
agent would fight him over because there
were you know crappy teenage romantic
comedies because he only wanted to work
on projects that he believed in and that
got him very far he was you know
well-respected as a you know as a person
and as an actor people enjoyed working
with him and they were really awestruck
by him so you know versus you know some
of the other you know very bankable
actors in Hollywood who don't have carry
such great reputations we have the
instance of Heath who was really
well-liked among his peers and among the
fans clearly he you know he was troubled
and he was battling addiction and you
know he said to have become sober in the
past year you know privately to his
friends but you know clearly something
was amiss I think it's going to be very
easy for the media to say Heath is the
you know the next River Phoenix they're
also going to be looking for you know
with Brad Renfro now Heath Ledger who's
with the third celebrity who's going to
pass because because those deaths comes
in threes so I think there is a media
attachment to this story that may turn
it a bit sour when I don't know in all
certainty but I imagine this is you know
a very unfortunate singular instance of
you know a troubled guy who happens to
be in Hollywood perhaps I don't know
taking his own life
you